[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Colton I'm from Colby in
Northamptonshire I'm a gas engineer at
the moment from my own company had done
the hammer on my own company for about
13 years now I know you tuber myself I 4
million subscribers and I'm a pro
scooter athlete so I go to indoor skate
park skate parks do scooter tricks and
I'm here to learn about property and
connect with people who have experienced
and drive to scale and become successful
my favorite part is he comes from such a
place book oh yeah he just shed so much
information off the bat it doesn't try
and hide anything either exactly
administrative is that quest I don't
know it isn't it
[Music]
I want something different now something
this not so much working out maybe
working smarter not harder
so the main reason to come equals to see
him by you know Steve for myself him
doing things and how many operates and
how it's done not me thinking how it's
done actually see done in person who so
I've been I've been an accidental
landlord for about 12 years the house I
was living in I sold a pair of effects
now now we moved back into the property
that we were renting out and we're in
the process of refurb in that so that we
can then rent out how to refinance it to
the spot slight little pot the crash
course I would say is the best
foundational event like in property and
I would say they're very similar they're
different though every single time
because the people and also like every
single time I hear something different
that I may have had before but now I
like understand it my favorite part is
when he actually demonstrated it they
just showed how
and you just need that little bit of
confidence yes exactly
[Music]
I want to go at this finding another
string to my boat to give me more
confidence to go ahead so I'll be
looking to further my training and like
I've learned from Sammy leads at the
moment is what you get is what you
invest in yourself
I realize that their retirement they
think the thought of working and the
best thing is to do an event like this
is Network is you're gonna meet people
who have already got books and you're
gonna meet you know accountants you get
me mortgage advisers and the values
contacts that are gonna make you work
you in the long run
I'm fully educated about the basics
about how to find a deal what to look
for how to call up agents and I feel
very confident with us so I have a clear
vision of what to do I'm really excited
for this and I'm ready to go right now
[Music]
you